chilling effect when punishment for what
people say becomes widespread people
stop saying what they really think and
instead say whatever is needed to thrive
in the social environment thus limits on
speech become limits on sincerity
yeah so I mean
so this is you know a sort of very
timely thing I think because there's a
lot of talk about sort of suppressing
people from social media and stuff and
um I think people should really realize
that stopping people from airing their
true opinions doesn't change their
opinions it just makes them mask their
opinions
um and when this happens at scale it can
lead to all kinds of absurd situations
like the Abilene Paradox I don't know if
we've covered the Abilene Paradox run it
back it's basically a situation yeah
it's basically a situation where
everyone professes a belief that no one
actually believes purely because they
think everybody else believes it and so
you can have a situation where literally
everybody just is saying stuff that is
just not true for the sole reason that
they think everybody else thinks it's
true an example of this
um would probably be considered sort of
um the issue of what a woman is um
you've got pretty much everybody
in the mainstream culture now pretending
that they don't know what a woman is
um but if you were to ask these people
in private they would probably be able
to tell you they'll just probably say an
adult human female but because there's
this sort of stigma now around knowing
what a woman is
people
you know basically sort of they have to
pretend like they don't know and uh it's
just it leads to absurd situation after
absurd situation and that's why I think
it's
it's I mean there's many reasons there's
many arguments against censorship but
this is definitely one of the strongest
I think
um you're not by censoring people you're
not changing their behavior and changing
their opinions you're not changing their
beliefs all you're doing is just sort of
sweeping them under the carpet you know
and they're just going to continue just
you just won't be able to see it anymore
so you can't keep track of these people
anymore this ties into your view about
uh when people are their opinions they
feel like they have to have an opinion
on anything and everything and changing
your opinion is tantamount to
destruction of yourself
so because people value their opinions
so much
in this situation quite rightly you're
um the performative nature of having the
right opinion of the Abilene paradox
playing along with that has never been
more important because opinions have
never been more relevant to our status
within the world
yeah absolutely and you see this
reflected most in the precisely the
industries that you would expect it to
be reflected in I.E the industries that
are image oriented so if you have a look
at people who have the most fashionable
opinions I mean Rob Henderson would
probably call these luxury beliefs
they're sort of you know fashionable
opinions that people adopt in order to
sort of signal status
um you know when I was a kid
uh we all used to like buy sweatshirts
which had like brand names stamped
across the front of them like you know
Fila or Nike you know when you're a kid
at school because you want everybody to
know that you paid paid for it so
nowadays when you get older you no
longer wear these labels now it's
opinions instead uh you know you have
the she her and the he him instead of a
poor hot and poor them you know and um
it's sort of like
you see this in Hollywood you see it
amongst Hollywood actors you see it
amongst academics you see it in politics
you see it in all of the industries
where image is important where basically
appearing to have the right opinions is
more important than actually having the
correct opinions yes and it's also an
industry where opinions and actions have
never been more diverged right you know
somebody now can have a Twitter account
that proselytizes the right uh beliefs
and in private whole completely
different beliefs or the way that they
go about living their lives be totally
different you could be a an online vegan
who's an offline carnivore and for as
long as the twine shall never meet
uh it kind of doesn't really matter so
much whereas in the past your ability to
profess a belief that you didn't live up
to in reality would have been much more
difficult to diverge especially in
before the internet right or before
print media there is no way for you your
opinions are very much your actions
right there is no way to do this and to
bifurcate you and what you say from what
you and what you are and what you do so
yeah it's
um
the opportunity and the motive have
aligned to uh create this chilling
effect
yeah absolutely people have what their
digital age has done is it's separated
the person from the persona
um so now you know there's a much wider
Gulf between how you appear to others
and how you actually are than there ever
was because of the sort of importance of
social media in our daily lives and so
because of that sort of dissociation
there's now big Gulf between
the beliefs that people profess and
what they actually believe in real life
there's no consequences nowadays for
what a person actually believes really
most of the time anyway at least as long
as you have the fashion opinions you
know if you have unfashionable opinions
then there is consequences but if you if
you believe something like for instance
um
uh that
it's not a problem for
um
like for instance there was this issue
in Scotland recently about um that there
was a rapist who was locked in a women's
prison briefly and then there was an
outcry about it over the Internet which
sort of LED Nicholas sturgeon to walk it
back and may have led to her resignation
um but I mean if you're like a a really
really sort of uh
rich
Hollywood actor
um and you you know you you've got no
you know nobody who's going to go to
prison there's nobody in your life who's
ever gone to prison or anything like
that uh you don't need to worry about
anybody you know being hurt by your
opinions on whether women should because
whether a trans rapist should be allowed
in a woman's prison so you're not paying
the consequences other people are paying
the consequences and you could say the
same thing about black crime rates or
whatever you know people say that
um you know black people are being shot
at a disproportionate rate
um by police
um and that this is purely due to
systemic racism
um you know if you're a Hollywood actor
you don't need to worry about uh the
true causes of the sort of uh crime
rates in in in like neighborhoods so you
could just say yeah
or the outcomes of defunding the police
right defund the police perfect example
of this say it but yeah yours isn't the
neighborhood where you need police in
any case what's happening people if you
enjoyed that then press here for the
full unedited episode and don't forget
to subscribe
face
[Music]
foreign